the world of augmented reality or ar has
been totaled as one of the most
profitable industries analysts believe
the augmented reality market would reach
200 billion usd in 2025
a major shift in public perception
occurred when ar effects found their way
to instagram and facebook
using these filters can be very
beneficial from a marketing point of
view should you need to shore up your
business end with some bleeding edge
deck
today we will cover the basics of the
spark ar studio offered by meta to get
you started as a spark ar creator as
quickly as possible but before we begin
you must know that spark is updated
rather frequently
should you find yourself unfamiliar with
the user interface as seen in today's
video you can download the version 133
executable file from the description
below to maintain coherency throughout
the tutorial
with that being said let's familiarize
ourselves with the user interface from
the spark ar studio in the first section
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
the first time the sparky studio is
launched post installation we get a
screen like this
there are multiple sections over here
including the create new section where
we can create a new project where we can
start working on ai effects for
instagram and facebook we have the learn
section over here where you can watch
some tutorials that have already been
set up by other people to get you
started on your first project and we
have some intermediate tutorials as well
in the recent project section you're
going to find any other project that you
have created or some other project file
that you loaded from the hard drive
which can be opened from the open
section using the file explorer as well
the watch now section keeps you updated
with the developments of the sparc ar
studio and the new features and
improvements that have been coming to
the latest updates in this profile
the creator community is the facebook
group where spark ar creators join
together and share their experiences and
creations it is highly recommended to
join so that you can be aware of the
power and the features of the sparky
studio while getting some new ideas for
your own project as well the community
forum is a helpful tool for beginners
with users can direct the questions to
experienced users so they can get the
doubts clear regarding projects features
or even some tutorials that you are
trying to follow for now we're going to
create a new project and we're going to
start a blank one
there are multiple templates that we can
use that have some pre assets loaded but
to get acquainted with the interface
we're going to start out with a blank
project and work our way from there
and here we have
a sparky studio project
the first thing that can be seen on the
interface is the screen over here
this small window is known as the
simulator this basically is a
representation of how the er effects
that you create will be shown on the
receiver screen
you can undock it to move it around
freely across the screen so that you can
arrange it according to your preferred
workflow you can resize it depending on
how you want to keep it as a display
screen or you can dock it again after
changing the size just behind the
simulator we have the viewport the
viewport acts as a 3d representation of
the ar effects the small box over here
can act as your mobile device or any
other handheld device that can process
ai effects
the spike screen over here is the mobile
screen which is already being shown on
the simulator
the blank space in between both these
models is a 3d space where the ar
effects are going to occur it helps
create a real world emphasis on how the
air effects are going to be applied on
the models that are being shown on the
simulator we have the asset explorer
over here where we can load 3d objects
textures and some sound bytes that can
be used in the ai effects
however just loading these assets is not
the end of the game as we need to load
them onto the scene hierarchy over here
the asset explorer just ensures that we
have those assets to load onto the scene
once we add them to the scene hierarchy
we can see the effect directly showing
up on the simulator over here
we also have the property editor over
here where we can adjust fine tune
parameters according to how we want to
shape our effects for example if we
change on directional light we can see
we have the options to change the
visibility the color intensity and other
small parameters of the directional
light
this is basically all the things that
you can need to change the effects
regarding the simulator you can even
change the model that appears in the
screen in the video section you have
multiple simulated characters that can
help fine-tune your effects to different
real-world models be beat with glasses
facial hair skin tones among other
things
this is the complete workspace of the ar
spark studio
now that you're familiar with the
interface
let's start creating a first effect and
share it through others for testing
we're going to start creating our first
ai effect from the sparky studio using
the asset explorer
you can import effects directly from the
computer hard drive or we can use the
asset library that comes pre-built with
sparkier studio
for now we're going to use the asset
library over here
once clicked we can see there are
multiple sections over here the 3d
objects are mostly shared from either
facebook or sketchfab
sketchpav is a very good resource for
getting textures and 3d models that can
be used in ai effects however be sure to
check the licensing before sharing them
publicly
the music and sound are useful sound
bites that are mostly from facebook
sound design labs which can be used for
free in your ar effects
the patch assets and script packages
help you to add animations and some kind
of logic to your effects these can help
your movements and the different effects
to go from one piece to the other apart
from some static effects like makeup etc
both textures and color luts help you
fine tune the color that is being shown
on the ar effect currently it helps to
add some tinting and other textures that
can fine tune your effects to show more
depth or brightness contrast etc
blocks are a collection of objects 3d
models and sometimes even sound bite
blocks are usually created for a
particular purpose as we are going to
use them right now
we're going to click on view all
and we're going to open the makeup block
to load this block onto your sparkir
studio just click on import free and
wait for it to download the effects
once the effects are downloaded you can
see the makeup block being added onto
the asset explorer over here click on
done
and we can close the air library for now
as you can see the makeup effect doesn't
show up on the simulator right now this
is because even if we have loaded the
asset we're going to have to add it to
the scene
for it to show up on the simulator and
the viewport
as you can see we can see the ar effect
showing up on the simulator right now
this is an exact representation of how
this effect is going to be shown on
other people's mobile devices when they
use this particular effect as you can
see the property inspector over here can
help you fine tune many of the
parameters you can adjust multiple
properties of this particular effect
for example it can change the eyeliner
color the eyeliner opacity the eyeshadow
obesity among other things
for example if you want to see something
stark we can change the lips color over
here
from peach to something dark so that it
can show up on our simulator directly
as you can see the changes get affected
directly and immediately now these
things can be tested over multiple
models and even a front camera if you
need to do so so that we can check for
consistencies across different shapes
sizes skin tones facial hair etc this is
just one block that can be used to show
how effective the proper inspector is in
fine tuning these effects
for example we can add another block on
top of this one
we're going to use the asset library
we're going to go to blocks
and we can take the eye color block for
example
we're going to use the same process of
clicking on import free
click on done
and just like that we have to add it
onto the scene for it to show up on the
simulator as you can see there has been
a change in the eye color of the model
we can change across different variables
and different camera models to show the
effect more clearly
and particularly the eye color effect
you can see what are the different
parameters that can be adjusted beat
iris colors the iris opacity the iris
scale etc this is how you can create
your first effect on the spark ar studio
now when it comes to sharing these
effects you can click this button over
here which is a test on device button
and you can send these to your instagram
or the facebook accounts
now these effects won't be launched
publicly and be shared with multiple
users unless you choose to do so
explicitly however this can be used to
test on how the air effects can be shown
on real world mobile devices and serve
as a great example of how you can test
out these effects after creating your ar
effect be sure to save your project
when you save an ar studio project it
takes the assets that you have loaded
the changes that you have done in the
property inspector and save them in a
folder format for easier saving and for
portability reasons
should you need to share the project or
need to work on different devices you
can just move those folder and share it
with the respective team members to
continue work on the same project
without having to create everything from
scratch again this is how you can create
your first air effect on the spark ah
studio you can share these effects for
testing among your friends and other
family members
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here